pero es una carrera contra el tiempo los
bomberos luchan contra un incendio en
las laderas del parque nacional de
hibble mountain en sudáfrica
el incendio se ha hecho con parte de la
universidad de ciudad del cabo
obligando a evacuar a cientos de
estudiantes las llamas han causado
estragos en la histórica biblioteca de
la universidad destruyendo libros
manuscritos y documentos de valor
incalculable como conflictos contra el
apartheid no obstante algunas de las
obras más importantes de la biblioteca
se han salvado gracias a la rápida
activación de puertas corredizas
en el campus hay más de 10 vehículos de
bomberos actualmente hay 3 edificios que
están ardiendo esporádicamente pero el
que es uno de nuestros mayores problemas
es la biblioteca en la que hay
muchísimos objetos de valor antiguos
otros edificios del campus también se
han incendiado mientras que este famoso
molino de viento que data de 1796 ha
quedado parcialmente destruido justo
fuera del campus en las inmediaciones de
table mountain el viento ha propagado
las llamas por el parque nacional a una
velocidad alarmante se ha instado a los
excursionistas a abandonar el lugar ya
los conductores a retirar sus vehículos
más de 150 bomberos están en primera
línea si quiere que la causa del
incendio forestal que estalló el domingo
por la mañana es un fuego de los
habitantes de la calle desatendido las
autoridades han advertido que la lucha
contra las llamas podría durar días